[Musica]
cosa rende un leader efficace se cerchiamo su
Google la parola
leader otteniamo più di 300 milioni di visite
su Amazon ci sono più di 50
mila libri su argomenti di leadership nella
mia esperienza professionale come leadership
coach e trainer Collaboro con
molti leader potenziali leader manager
e quando sono in una stanza con loro chiedo
chi è un leader efficace e
ricevo molte risposte diverse perché di
solito ci sono molti stili
e approcci diversi alla leadership ma alla
fine tutti gli stili devono essere efficaci
se è in  un mondo di
politica aziendale o di vita quotidiana oggi
viviamo in un mondo c'è un mondo complesso,
imprevedibile e competitivo in cui le
organizzazioni operano in un
ambiente globale che richiede continuamente
nuovi prodotti e nuovi servizi per soddisfare
le esigenze di nuovi mercati e nuovi
clienti per essere efficaci  e per guidare l'
innovazione il contesto in cui
viviamo richiede ai leader una nuova
diversità di capacità di leadership e
incl  sione che può essere integrata
all'aspetto centrale della leadership come la
comunicazione, la consapevolezza di sé che influenza gli
altri e la capacità di apprendere e
adattare ciò che intendiamo per diversità e
inclusione per usare un'analogia diversità
e inclusione è come un'orchestra
che suonerò  un po' di musica e
vorrei che ti concentrassi su ogni singolo
strumento musicale
[Musica]
[Musica] la
diversità è come ogni singolo
strumento musicale che è unico sforzi l'
inclusione è come tutti gli strumenti che
suonano insieme che creano una bella
sinfonia e l'inclusione  il leader è
come il maestro il direttore d'orchestra che
ascolta e coordina l'unicità
degli strumenti musicali quando in
un'organizzazione abbiamo una forza lavoro diversificata
e il leader può sfruttare i punti
di forza della diversità di pensieri che provengono da
persone con background culturale diverso
età esperienza orientamento sessuale di genere
o neurodiversità in
un'organizzazione un leader può sfruttare
la diversità di pensieri che abbiamo
un'inclusione e il leader possono sfruttare
le conoscenze UH significate e valorizzare il
valore della diversità di pensieri per fare
un esempio un paio di anni fa
un'azienda chiamata Mattel un'azienda di giocattoli ha
deciso di lanciare un nuovo prodotto una
pasta per bambole che sarebbe stata  commercializzato
ai bambini afroamericani al fine di
garantire che le bambole fossero culturalmente
sensibili, l'alta dirigenza ha deciso
di arruolare il
gruppo di risorse dei dipendenti afroamericani di Mattel per
guidare il team di marketing attraverso il
lancio del prodotto oggi è uno
dei migliori dell'azienda-  vendendo
marchi di minoranza focalizzati come Mattel molte altre
aziende stanno abbracciando la diversità e l'
inclusione perché conoscono il valore
di sfruttare le intuizioni uniche e XP che
i dipendenti portano in tavola la mia
preoccupazione come donna e come leadership
coach è quella che stiamo facendo dei
progressi  verso la diversità e l'inclusione
ci sono ancora delle barriere nei confronti delle
donne e delle minoranze infatti le donne
rimangono ancora  sottorappresentato nel consiglio di
amministrazione e nel comitato esecutivo
dove vengono prese le decisioni e lascia che ti faccia
una domanda quante donne in questa
stanza sono state l'unica donna in una
stanza al lavoro nella loro carriera per favore
alzi la mano ok vedo è la
maggioranza  una donna su cinque afferma di essere
spesso l'unica donna in una stanza
al lavoro e l'80% delle donne
a livello dirigenziale ha riferito di aver
subito micro aggressioni che impiegano
donne e minoranze non riguarda solo
questioni sociali o morali, ma si tratta anche
di includere  loro nel
processo decisionale e nelle attività chiave e si
tratta di valutare i contributi, quindi
come colmare il divario di inclusione nella mia
esperienza professionale Credo che
dobbiamo iniziare dall'alto verso il basso con
un leader inclusivo che renda l'
inclusione della diversità al centro delle organizzazioni
valori ed è consapevole dei punti ciechi personali e
organizzativi, inoltre l'
inclusione della diversità deve essere supportata a ogni
singolo livello di gestione  l con impegno
attraverso azioni in modo da creare un
ambiente inclusivo in cui tutti i
dipendenti si sentano al sicuro nel parlare
dove sono apprezzati, apprezzati e
consapevoli di avere un senso di appartenenza,
ovviamente, i cambiamenti richiedono tempo e per
ottenere la diversità l'inclusione in
un'organizzazione o in un'azienda è  un
processo non facile che nelle organizzazioni
solo il vantaggio sostenibile è il suo
capitale umano e investire in modo più efficace
nelle persone e nel potenziale delle persone può
rendere un'organizzazione pronta a competere
e prosperare in questo mondo in rapido cambiamento
più in generale immagina se tutti i paesi
tutte le nazioni credono nelle persone
potenziale avremmo un mondo migliore
un giorno è più inclusivo ed
equo possono trasformare una futura parità e
qualità della vita grazie
[Applausi]